[Music]
researchers have detected strange radio
signals coming from deep space these
mysterious radio waves might just be
bursts of cosmic energy from a distant
neutron star or it could be that
scientists have discovered a highly
Advanced civilization 90 light years
away from
Earth so
what kind of civilization would have the
ability to send strong signals like this
well scientists classify civilizations
on something called the kardashev scale
it's a scale that measures a
civilization's technological ability to
harness energy while it's a hypothetical
scale that could eventually have five or
more levels most scientists only refer
to the first few but don't be
underwhelmed we're the only civilization
we know of and technically we're still
stuck on type
zero at this stage we've managed to
harness some but not all of our planet's
potential energy we consume about 18
trillion watts of power every year and
if we wanted to bump ourselves up to a
type 1 civilization we'd need to consume
over 500 times that every second to do
this we'd need to harness store and
utilize all of the energy available to
us that includes all raw materials and
every bit of sunlight that reaches Earth
we'd also have to tame volcanos
earthquakes and other Natural
Forces at the rate at which we're
developing now it's possible that we
could be a type 1 civilization within
the next 200 years
but whatever civilization scientists may
have discovered in the far reaches of
space could already be a type 2
civilization or
higher once our civilization has all of
the energy available on our home planet
under control and we graduate to a type
one on the cesf
scale then we need to take the next step
time to crank up our energy consumption
to 10 billion times what it was before
to do this we'd need to harness not just
all the solar energy that reaches Earth
we'd need all of the energy our star
generates
period if there is a type two
civilization out there they're probably
using an incredible system to do this a
Dyson
Sphere they'd build this Mega structure
around their star to collect all the
energy it radiates out in every
direction they could even assemble other
Dyson spheres around the first Dyson
Sphere to guarantee that little to know
energy
escapes but there's nothing simple about
this technology and that's why only
Advanced civilizations could construct
something like it for one a Dyson Sphere
must be larger than the star
itself and if these Mega structures are
bigger than Stars well they should be
easy to spot right well this could be
tricky once a civilization is finished
building the Dyson Sphere the mega
structure blocks nearly all of the
visible light from its star a
civilization this Advanced could make
its own solar system
invisible lucky for us visible light
isn't the only way to detect a star even
with a Dyson Sphere blocking its light a
star would still radiate heat and we
could detect the Star by the infrared
light it gives
off but that wouldn't be the only way we
might discover a civilization this
Advanced remember that strange radio
signal it originated about 90 light
years away from Earth coming from the
Star HD1 16459 5 was this powerful radio
signal created by an alien race and
intentionally pointed toward Earth a
civilization able to pull this off would
need to be far more advanced than our
own this type 2 civilization would be
able to utilize the raw materials on
every planet in its star system and
maybe even Beyond they may have built
Fusion reactors that orbit their Planet
fueled with gas from other worlds with
hydrogen-rich
atmospheres and they might be mining
precious metals from rocky planets just
like like Earth they could terraform
other planets into livable worlds for
their populations and they wouldn't live
in fear of civilization ending natural
disasters like asteroid impacts ice ages
or global warming because they'd have
Technical Solutions for these too this
alien civilization would be at the stage
on the kardashev scale where they'd be
able to master Interstellar travel but
if that's true there should be no reason
for them not to pop by for a visit
right well not so fast with all the
advanced technology they might have at
their disposal these aliens could be
waiting for us to catch up that way when
our civilizations meet we would do so as
equal
Partners who knows they could be so
Advanced that they're no longer a fully
biological race they could be more like
cyborgs with a mix of robotic and organ
organic
material this would make them capable of
incredible things that humans could only
dream of but they wouldn't stop there an
advanced world like this would want to
go farther up the kardashev scale and as
they became a Type 3 civilization they'd
rely on something other than the power
of their own star system they would
harness the power of several stars in
their
Galaxy with this much power a
civilization would have no problem
meeting its ever growing energy needs
they'd just hook up another star when
they needed more
power if we ever Advanced to this level
we'd have 100 billion stars available to
harness in the Milky Way galaxy alone a
civilization like this would no doubt be
the rulers of their Galaxy and they'd
have the power to move entire star
systems merging them to harvest the
energy they need more efficient ly so if
one of these civilizations existed well
you could detect them by observing the
sudden disappearance of many stars in a
far away Galaxy this could be a sign
that Dyson spheres have been constructed
around not just one but several
Stars a Type 3 civilization could
already be out there after all
scientists have announced that they
found two galaxies with a highly unusual
amount of infrared light this is
something we usually observe in galaxies
where new stars are being born but some
unusual and sudden spikes in infrared
light could mean that we found the first
signs that civilizations many times more
advanced than us exist maybe they're
about to make contact or maybe they
already
have no one knows what to expect if we
encountered other forms of alien life
would they talk like us look like us or
would they be completely
different What If instead of
encountering organic alien life we met
alien artificial
intelligence what would alien technology
look
like what might it be able to
do and should we be afraid of something
like this
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we discovered alien
AI Humanity has dreamed up some pretty
crazy technology and we're not too far
away from having our Tech look like it's
come out of a sci-fi
movie but it's safe to say that if
aliens created technology it would be a
lot different than anything we could
dream of so what types of alien AI could
could we possibly
see nobody knows what life on other
planets will be like but the first form
of alien technology we could encounter
might be some sort of Alien Probe to
help us explain what an Alien Probe
would be like we're collaborating with
YouTuber Isaac Arthur Isaac hosts a
YouTube channel explaining science and
futurism
Concepts thanks Peter this probe would
be tasked with finding or communicating
with us
the probe would fly throughout the
Galaxy in an attempt to find some sort
of life it would either be wandering and
searching aimlessly or it would have
some designated Mission and once that's
completed it would record any signals it
found and transmit them back to the
alien home world the issue with this is
us being able to discover it space is
big really really big and the Alien
Probe might be too far away for us to
detect it it might not want to community
communicate with us and if it does we
might not know how to receive its
message or understand what the Alien
Probe is trying to say to us that might
be some strange Concepts too as an alien
AI might have very different motivations
from anything biological so that it
might be form us it planed to stop by
and turn off into a quintilian
paperclips for an in-depth look at the
kinds of motivations and psychology it
might have try out our episode alien AI
back to you Peter thanks Isaac so if we
can't communicate with the aliens and
they're just simply observing us what
would happen next well now that we've
been discovered by alien technology a
number of things could happen we could
witness more of their technology coming
to Earth this could be in the form of a
machine that could terraform our entire
planet this would be very very bad
that's because this this form of alien
technology would be used to alter our
Earth in whichever way its creators
pleased they might want to change
Earth's atmosphere temperature or
physical features and in the process the
human race would most likely become
extinct no matter how many missiles and
bullets we throw towards this thing
there would be virtually no way we could
stop it I mean come on this thing is
meant to completely alter planets you
think a gun will help you fight it off
if we're lucky enough to avoid our home
planet being taken over we may get sent
raw material drones this form of AI
would Harvest metals and gases from us
and bring them back home yeah this would
still suck but we could at least have
some chance of surviving this
one okay now we've seen the alien
technology but when do we get to meet
the actual aliens you know the green
guys with the funny heads well there's
two ways this could go one is that the
aliens come and they take over our
planet and resources but we have a
separate story for that one called what
if aliens arrived tomorrow the second
option is that we wouldn't see any
aliens at all that's because with all
this incredibly Advanced alien
technology there's the possibility that
the aliens aren't even around anymore
just like the way we fear Ai and robots
are taking over humans that may have
happened to aliens while they were
creating this Advanced AI the aliens may
have given it too much power and once
that happened their AI took over and
extinguished the alien race and then we
could have the exact same thing
threatening to destroy us so as cool as
it might sound alien AI would definitely
not be a cool thing for us to come up
against attention human you are
receiving an Interstellar radio
transmission and it could be coming from
one of the nearest exoplanets Proxima
centu
B what conditions make this planet a
candidate for alien
life what types of civilizations could
have flourished there and should we
expect them to be knocking on Earth's
door any day
now this is what if and here's what
would happen if there were an alien
civilization on Proxima
B at a distance of 4.2 light years away
Proxima centu is one of the closest
stars to our sun in
2016 a planet was discovered orbiting in
Proxima Cent's goldilock Zone that's
where conditions for liquid water could
exist meet Proxima b a planet that
registers at
0.87 on the earth similarity Index this
scale measures how similar a planet or
moon is to Earth and anything above 0.8
is considered earthlike as another
example Mars has an ESI of
0.64 in 20 20 astronomers recorded a
mysterious radio signal coming from the
direction of proximus centor could it be
that an alien civilization was
attempting to contact
us though Proxima B is similar to Earth
life forms on this Alien Planet would
likely develop very differently for
starters the planet is about 20 times
closer to its star than Earth is to the
sun and it only needs 11.2 days for one
full Revolution that's a lot of New
Year's celebrations but still Proxima B
receives about the same amount of solar
energy as Earth and that's because
Proxima centu is an mtype Red Dwarf star
compared to our gtype star these stars
are generally cooler in a range of 2200
to 3200 de
C but they would be some extreme
conditions that an alien civilization
would have to adapt to these
extraterrestrials would need to be able
to withstand radiation and lots of it
the planet receives about 400 times more
x-rays than Earth and dwarf stars like
proximus Sor give rise to coronal mass
ejections that would blast the planet
with lethal
radiation without a protective
atmosphere this would be be deadly for
any potential life forms another
challenge for a Proxima be civilization
would be tidal locking that's when a
planet takes the same amount of time to
spin on its axis as it does to orbit its
star imagine living where you
permanently face the scorching sun while
the other side of the earth is in a
constant state of Frozen
Darkness this is what life would be like
on this exoplanet C izations on Proxima
B would likely develop in the so-called
Terminator zones these are the strips of
Twilight between the day side and the
night side here winds would carry warm
air and create life-supporting
conditions and Aliens would build
thermal reactors with the mix of cool
and hot water to have that H2O always
available but if civilizations appeared
on either of the sides of the Terminator
Zone they'd need to develop different
survival tactics but collaboration and
unity could allow them to supply each
other with heat or ice effectively and
if a civilization developed on the light
side would they even know that there
were other stars or objects in the
universe would they even think about
other life out in
space that brings us back to the radio
signal the Breakthrough listen project
recorded in
2020 this signal occupied a very narrow
band of the radio spectrum at 982
mahz this is startling because it's a
portion of the spectrum rarely used by
human-made
transmitters researchers haven't ruled
out the possibility that these signals
originated on Earth but there are many
unanswered questions one thing they're
sure of it didn't come from from a
natural world only manufactured or
alien-made technology seems to produce
signals like
that so if an advanced civilization was
trying to communicate with us from
Proxima what would their society be
like they could be a type one
civilization like us and use the energy
available from their Planet like oil
wind or geothermal power
or they could be a typee 2 civilization
using energy on the scale of their
planetary system that would mean they
were thousands of years more advanced
than us would they have developed
complex languages and live in cities
would they have Democratic forms of
governance or would they live under the
rule of a
dictator you must have so many questions
for our alien neighbors and they would
have so many questions for you or maybe
they already know
everything
unfortunately we likely won't be able to
visit them anytime soon using current
Technologies it would still take between
19,000 and 81,000 years to reach them of
course maybe they could travel faster
than the speed of light and get here
first thousands of light years from
Earth there could be another planet
hospitable to life Kepler
69c and you're about to travel to this
alien world to see that life with your
own
eyes what would it be like to make this
Epic Journey so far across the
universe what kind of planet would you
be likely to finded upon
arrival and if you did discover Life
what would it look
like this is what if and here's what
would happen if there's life on Kepler
69c located
2,383 light years from Earth in the
signis constellation is a potential
super Earth at least that's what it's
often referred to as Kepler 69c is an
exoplanet about 1.7 times larger ger
than our planet and it could also be
around 3 and 1 half times more
massive but there's a catch we don't
really know if this planet is located
within the habitable zone of its
star if it's too close Kepler 69c would
be too hot for liquid water to exist on
its surface if it's too far from its Sun
well then it would be nothing more than
a frigid world what we do know is that
Kepler 69c orbits its star about 40%
closer than Earth orbits the Sun and
that could mean that it isn't actually a
super Earth it could be a super
Venus so if you traveled all the way
here would you find life or a thick
scorching atmosphere boiling every drop
of water on the
planet before you begin your journey to
Kepler 69c there'd be one very important
thing to keep in mind it's far away
almost 600 times further away than
Proxima centuri our closest neighboring
star even if you could travel say 1% of
the speed of light you wouldn't get
there anytime soon at this speed you
could whip around Earth in just over for
13 seconds but to get to Kepler
69c well that would take you about
238,000 years to even make this trip
possible you'd need a super Advanced
hibernation pod you know you don't want
to grow too old and die before you could
even get to your
destination am I right well hibernation
technology that could help you sleep for
over 200,000 years doesn't exist yet but
hey this is what if anything's
possible by the time your ship makes its
arrival any life that may exist on
Kepler 69c today could evolve or Advance
into something entirely different think
about it this way 300,000 years ago
humans were just beginning to create
stone tools and Spears and look at you
now making a trip across the Galaxy
looking back at the planet you left
behind who knows what changes would
happen to our human civilization during
your trip no matter what it's way too
late to turn around now based on the
planet's distance from its star we know
that Kepler 69c receives a similar
amount of sunlight as Venus and despite
being more massive than Earth it has a
relatively low density all this means is
that instead of metals this rocky planet
is made of silicate and carbonate
minerals that could make things a little
complicated you see with all these
minerals in the crust Kepler 69c could
have a really thick atmosphere and to
make matters worse this atmosphere would
be composed mostly of carbon
dioxide uhoh did you choose the wrong
super earth to travel to yeah if Kepler
69c is anything like Venus it would be a
pretty hot planet all because similar to
Venus its clouds would trap the Heat and
create an extreme greenhouse effect
Kepler 69 C's atmosphere would be caught
in an endless cycle of getting thicker
and
hotter but nobody said this world should
be habitable for you oh no once you took
off your helmet you'd instantly melt and
suffocate like I said life on this
planet would be completely different
from what you'd
imagine as you made your approach you'd
find surface temperatures as high as
475° C and the atmospheric pressure
would be over 90 times that of Earth at
sea level it would be like being 900 M
deep in the ocean except you'd be on dry
land with conditions like this you'd
likely not find anything resembling an
ocean here just like on Venus the high
temperatures would boil away all the
water whatever life you could
potentially encounter on this planet it
would need to be able to survive in
these brutal conditions or it would have
to exist somewhere else besides the
surface one place you could discover
Life on Kepler 69c would be up in the
clouds around 50 km up temperatures
would be much much cooler they would
range from about 30 to 70° C and with
its low density this planet could have a
surface gravity that would be just over
70% of what's found on Earth this weaker
gravity could allow life forms to thrive
in the sky where Kepler 69c is most
hospitable
life could just be floating freely in
the
atmosphere this would be another way in
which this planet could have far more in
common with Venus than with Earth probes
around Venus have picked up traces of a
gas that could be a potential sign of
life
phosphine if you discovered phosphine in
Kepler 69 C's atmosphere it could be the
result of bacteria that don't require
oxygen to
survive but be ready to hold your nose
this smelly gas has an odor similar to
decaying fish on earth the bacteria that
produce phosphine often live in swamps
or Wetlands but on Venus or Kepler 69c
this bacteria could exist in the thick
oxygenless atmosphere
itself so in the end you may have
traveled a very very long way to find
the smallest and stinkiest of life forms
now on the upside you've just discovered
extraterrestrial
[Music]
life what if you found out that you had
a long lost
relative and what if that long lost
relative was from a different planet in
our galaxy and what if this far away
planet was home to billions of humans
just like
Earth but these humans don't look
anything like us because they're from
the
future could aliens be future versions
of
humans how far ahead of us would they
be how much would they have
evolved would we be able to understand
each
other and what would meeting future
humans mean for Humanity on
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens were future
humans in
1947 a mysterious object crashed in the
desert near Roswell New
Mexico you all know this story but could
it really be aliens
the mysterious object was officially
declared to be a US Army Air Force
balloon but then decades later US Navy
Commander George W Hoover who had top
secret clearance revealed that the
mysterious crash involved time trving
humans somehow these future humans had
developed the technology to overcome the
technological limitations that prevent
us present day humans from making the
same type of
trip some theories suggest that these
future humans travel back in time in
order to understand their biological
past maybe these same time travelers
helped our ancestors to make huge leaps
in scientific and technological
knowledge in a relatively short amount
of
time but if any of these theories are
true should we be prepared for another
alien human visit sometime in the near
future and what might we expect from
this Close Encounter of the Third
Kind if aliens I mean future humans were
to come and visit us again they would
probably look similar to how they appear
in
movies like us they'd still walk on two
feet but their heads and their eyes
would be much
larger this fits with predictions of how
present day humans will continue to
evolve we can expect our heads to be
bigger and our upper skull to become
more rounded to accommodate a larger
brain and as our civilization advances
enough for interplanetary travel our
eyes would get bigger so we can see
better in dimmer environments that are
further away from the
Sun future humans might also find a way
to slow the Aging
process so it would be possible to make
several trips to places thousands of
light years away within one lifetime if
we want to travel somewhere that's
60,000 light years away and if our
technology could do it then it would be
a 60-year flight for anyone on board but
when they got back to Earth 60,000 years
would have passed we'd like to think
that humans of the future would solve
this problem so they could visit Earth
and come home to tell their family and
friends about their
trip but if future humans find a way to
live for thousands of years would that
lead to a massive overpopulation on
whichever Planet they
inhabit well chances are if they make it
possible to live that long they will
probably succeed in optimizing their
existence before that their civilization
would undoubtedly be a lot more
efficient than our s the reason being is
that they could be centuries if not
Millennia ahead of us in evolutionary
terms future humans would be a lot
smarter and they'd have better
technology to maximize their space and
live in densely populated worlds without
producing the same high levels of
pollution that we do on Earth in fact
you could bet that future humans
wouldn't just have better technology
they'd be technology ology just like
some humans today have implants to
perceive sound or to detect atmospheric
pressure the humans of the future would
likely have dozens of technological
implants to make their lives
easier think about everything your cell
phone does for you now imagine you could
command it with your thoughts and that
it would only be a small chip in your
brain a chip or implant like that might
Al explain why those who claim to have
encountered aliens have said that the
aliens spoke to them in their native
language could future humans simply have
automatic language translators implanted
in their brains or would humans of the
future evolve past different
languages it's no secret that humans are
the Earth's most dominant species and
without proof of Life anywhere else in
the universe we can probably consider
ourselves the most dominant species in
space too but what if there were others
just like us millions of years ago how
do we even know that we're the first
Advanced civilization to call the planet
Earth home and if there have been others
what kind of traces have they left for
us to find this is what if and here's
what would happen if an advanced
civilization had already existed on
Earth we know that complex life has
existed on Earth for about 400 million
years but how could we look that far
back ancient ruins and artifacts only
take us back a few thousand years
geologic records only about 2 million so
if we can't rely on direct evidence then
where else could we find traces of a
potentially extinct
civilization and what can we learn to
make sure we avoid the same
fate here are some numbers to make your
brain hurt for a second the universe is
about 13.8 billion years old the Earth
is 4 1/2 billion years old and humans
have only developed our industrial
civilization in the last 300 years with
all that in mind it seems like there was
ample opportunity for another Advanced
civilization to emerge flourish and die
all before we even showed up but finding
any proof of a past civilized species
seems like it could be harder than even
starting the civilization itself
physical artifacts would be the most
concrete evidence of past intelligent
life but it's not very likely that we'll
ever find any over time even our tallest
buildings will crumble and our strongest
materials will disintegrate our cities
cover less than 1% of the Earth's
surface so any comparable cities from
past civilizations would be easy for
paleontologists to Miss Even if we knew
where to look it's unlikely that these
artifacts would last any longer than a
few million years sure there's always
fossilization but it only provides a
limited record of the past due to
variables like when they lived and where
an industrial civilization that lasted
100,000 years that's over 300 times
longer than us they might leave no
fossil Trace at all so maybe we're
better off looking for more indirect
evidence the best way to find that would
be to look at what traces our own
civilization would leave behind if it
collapsed in its current state one place
we're leaving a clear Trail is in the
sediment at the bottom of our bodies of
water one look at this stuff and you
would immediately see the wacky chemical
balances that would imply some sort of
outside influence for instance the
nitrogen fertilizers that we use to grow
food are running off into our bodies of
water and producing low oxygen dead
zones that would be visible in
sedimentary layers on top of that we'll
be leaving long- lasting synthetic
molecules from radioactive fallout
steroids and all the plastic we dump in
the ocean so yeah future species are
going to have a great impression of us
in case we're not embarrassed enough our
technological advances are rapidly
changing the environment which is
brought on widespread extinctions that
would be visible at fossil records
ironically perhaps the most promising
marker of an advanced civilization could
be one of the very things that brought
on its downfall when we burn fossil
fuels we are releasing carbon back into
the air fossil fuels ultimately derive
from decayed plants and animals which
contain a variety of carbon that has a
different atomic mass than most carbon
in our
atmosphere when this kind is released it
changes the molecular makeup of the
atmosphere and leaves a clear signal to
future scientists in a 2018 study
scientists hypothesized that
civilizations could even have fossil
fuel driven life cycles when fossil fuel
use leads to climate change the oxygen
levels decrease in the ocean and help
create a breeding ground for new fuels
like oil and coal in this way a
civilization and its demise might sew
the seed for new civilizations in the
future in our search for intelligent
Neighbors From the Past we may never
actually find any evidence but we can
learn a lot about ourselves analyzing
our own long-term ecological footprint
can have practical benefits it helps us
recognize where we can do better to
achieve a balance with our planet so
that we don't become the Forgotten
civilization of tomorrow while it
doesn't seem likely that intelligent
life was here before us that doesn't
mean there was wasn't any for all we
know they were so Advanced they were
able to clean up their mess as they
went do you ever feel like you're being
watched not by a creepy
stalker but by
aliens well it might be
happening just like we watch animals at
the zoo aliens may be out there watching
us like we're the zoo
animals but why exactly would they be
doing this in the first
place could they be afraid of
us this is what if and here's what would
happen if we lived in a galactic
Zoo imagine being trapped in a zoo well
if we really do live in a galactic Zoo
then you'd already be in one aliens
could be out there watching your every
move they may want to step study the
human race or learn from our
technology or maybe they're planning to
attack
us but what if instead of attacking us
the aliens are afraid of us attacking
them wait
what if you've watched any sort of
sci-fi movie you may think of aliens as
the bad guys the ones who attack our
planet and steal all our resources hey
shoot get out of there get away
get
go but never mind humans being afraid of
aliens they may be afraid of us think
about it it's entirely possible that
aliens have been watching Earth since
the birth of humanity if aliens have
been hanging around since the beginning
think of all the horrible destruction
they've seen humans cause deforestation
pollution and let's not forget about war
lots of War humans are constantly trying
to kill each other each other it's
estimated that almost 1 billion people
have died from war throughout
history so from the aliens perspective
humans might seem like an incredibly
violent scary species they may not want
to make contact because they're afraid
of how we might react which could very
well be with
violence and while aliens might be
watching us we aren't confined to a zoo
we have left the Earth and gone to the
Moon
but are we sure that intelligent life is
even out there well the odds are pretty
good the existence of alien life could
be explained by the fairy
Paradox we have our son but in the
universe there are billions of other
Suns and they're billions of years older
than our solar system orbiting these
other Suns could be earthlike planets
and on earthlike planets there's a good
chance of they being highly intelligent
life with so many worlds out there
there's an even better chance that at
least one of them has developed
Interstellar travel the fairy Paradox
suggests that with Interstellar travel
it would take a few million years to
travel through the entire Milky Way
galaxy you may think that sounds like an
incredibly long time but if there's a
civilization that is billions of years
older than us it would just be a tiny
fraction of their
history so if all this is true which is
very likely the aliens may have already
found us and apart from us being a
pretty violent species we may not be
interesting enough for them to make
contact with us we may just be another
life form out of the thousands or
millions that the aliens have
seen after all if you see an ant colony
on the ground do you try to make contact
with it you most likely go along with
your day to other life forms out there
we may just be a simple group of ants
ants they don't want to hurt or bother
just
observe another thing we have to keep in
mind is how we communicate with the
aliens ants in our world might be trying
to communicate with us but unless they
send the right signals we'll never know
the same goes for the aliens and us we
may not be communicating with the aliens
the right way they may not even know
that we want to make contact with them
so they just leave us
alone
aliens
enchiladas what is this world coming
to or should I say what is coming to
this
world this is what if and here's what
would happen if we found alien life on
Enceladus first of all it's pronounced
Enceladus not ENT chiladas sorry
muchacho Enceladus is Saturn's sixth
largest moon but it would be better
described as a winter
wonderland winter because it's covered
in ice and has an average surface
temperature of
-2° Wonder because just 40 km below its
surface are the ingredients for
life are there aliens out
there how long until we know know for
sure this is the W mangu geyser it
doesn't exist anymore but when it did it
could shoot water 460 M High making it
the largest geyser ever known on
Earth but beyond our atmosphere W mangu
has a drop in the bucket if you want to
see a real geyser you should book a trip
to Saturn in September 2005 NASA's
billion dooll cinii space probe was
approaching Saturn when it detected huge
eruptions at the southern pole of
Enceladus this tiny moon is roughly 25
times smaller than Earth but its geysers
are 8,000 times bigger than anything
recorded on our planet Cassini recorded
bursts that went as far as 240 km into
space which is about the distance from
Washington DC to
Philadelphia but if these bright Blooms
of mysterious Vapor were a sight to
behold scientists were more in awe of
what remained hidden beneath 40 km of
thick ice there's an ocean on Enceladus
and it's remarkably similar to the
oceans we have on Earth where life might
have
begun the data collected by the Cassini
space probe indicates that the water on
Enceladus is salty and is likely heated
by hydrothermal vents if enceladus's
ocean works like our own it's expected
that these subsurface vents expel
hydrogen en Rich hot water which mixes
with organic compounds to create amino
acids which combine to form proteins the
ingredients for life our planet is
estimated to be about 4 1/2 billion
years old the earliest evidence for life
on Earth comes from fossils that were
found in rocks that were roughly 3.7
billion years old today Enceladus is
estimated to be about 1 billion years
old which if it's following the
earthlike timeline would put it at the
right age to start supporting life but
considering that for 90% of our planet's
history life on Earth was microbial
chances are that alien life on Enceladus
would also be
microbial the big question is what might
these aliens look like we're talking
about creatures formed in cold dark
water with no access to sunlight how
would they interact with their
environment would they glow in the dark
or would they see without eyes how might
they evolve in size and in intelligence
and will we ever find them or will they
find
[Music]
us something is emerging from the
Mariana Trent it does not belong on this
planet if aliens lived in the deepest
place in the ocean what would they look
like how would they communicate with one
another and what would happen if we
dared to contact
them this is what if and here's what
would happen if there were aliens at the
bottom of the Mariana Trench there's a
reason why the idea of aliens living at
the bottom of the sea keeps popping up
in popular culture many of us are far
more afraid of what lies down there than
whatever's looking down at us from up in
space after all 80% of the ocean is
still unmapped and unexplored we have
better maps of the Moon Mars and Venus
than we do of our sea floor the most
mysterious part of our oceans is the
Mariana Trench it's deepest point the
Challenger Deep stretches 11 km down the
Mariana Trench is anything but a great
vacation spot no light is able to reach
its bottom and temperatures are just a
few degrees above
freezing not to mention it's crushingly
high water
pressure so how could aliens survive the
deepest spot in the
ocean the water pressure at the bottom
of the Mariana Trench is over 1,000
thousand times the atmospheric pressure
that you're used to at sea level this
kind of pressure would crush anything
even the toughest deep sea robots we've
ever built but some living things
managed to adapt and Thrive under such
pressing conditions like translucent
snailfish and sea
cucumbers the hidle snailfish known as
the deepest living fish FL ises at
depths of over 8
km unlike you deep sea fish don't have
pockets to store air in their bodies
that oxygen inside your lungs is what
gives you the feeling of pressure
whenever you take a dive no air means
this fish has a higher tolerance to the
weight of all that water Above It
Whatever aliens were lurking down below
would share the same
characteristic storing air just wouldn't
be their thing but what would they do
for
food well it's likely they'd imitate
their seafloor neighbors once again deep
sea creatures gorge on the decaying
remains of microbes algae or animals
from above our sunken ships might be
their version of a surprise Buffet any
extraterrestrial life down at the pit of
the trench would probably eat similar
food they'd burrow into the biggest
carcasses they could find and consume
what's left from the inside out like a
giant hagfish does or they might possess
enormous mouths and expandable
stomachs allowing them to catch and
digest large quantities of food as they
move and those big mouths of theirs
would also be filled with long fangs
pointed in inward this would enable them
to catch and hold on to other deep sea
creatures or you know any other prey
that just so happens to dive a little
too far from the surface hey don't judge
them in a habitat as precarious as the
Mariana Trench aliens would need to
capitalize on any and all sources of
nutrition they'd also have to go the
extra mile in order to let one another
know that they're out there in the pitch
dark
that's because sunlight can only travel
up to 1 km into the ocean anywhere
deeper than that and you wouldn't be
able to see a thing so how would our
underwater aliens put the notice out
that they're
around well two ideas by sound and by
light they produce themselves like
fireflies deep sea creatures are able to
produce and emit their own light thanks
to a process called
bioluminescence with it aliens would be
able to connect with each other through
specific lighting patterns for
longdistance communication they could
send out sound waves across enormous
distances in the water like the humpback
whale who's able to sing in the
Caribbean and be heard off the west
coast of Ireland 6,400 km
away now what would first contact with
this underwater species look like for
us well we'd have to get there first
we'd need a vessel strong enough to
withstand the constantly intensifying
pressure the tiniest of cracks would
squash you and your submarine faster
than you can say human Jam once down
there we'd have to take into account
that living at the bottom of the sea
would be like living on another planet
Planet if aliens existed in the
otherworldly depths of the Mariana
Trench this entire
time they may not want to be friendly
neighbors and the Darkness alone would
make it difficult to locate and study
our
subjects before approaching these
extraterrestrials we'd have to assess
their communication style first slowly
and patiently we'd need to understand
how they interact with their environment
too that is assuming they don't feel
threatened by our presence and decide to
do something about it trust goes both
ways when you're trying not to be
crushed or eaten in the name of
[Music]
science scientists have pieced together
a pretty clear picture of what life was
like on Earth thousands even millions of
years ago but if you fast forward 1
million years from now would alien
civilization be doing the same to learn
about
us what would Earth look like 1 million
years from
now what remains of human civilization
would still be
around and would we end up clones in a
human version of Jurassic
Park this is what if and here's what
would happen if Al ions came to Earth a
million years in the
future we're living in The anthropos
Scene Epic and in this historical period
the human impact on the world around us
has been significant enough to
geologically alter it 100 years from now
it could be an era defined by ecological
collapse and mass
extinction big bummer right now there's
no way for us to know how or when our
species may take its final walk on our
home planet a team of alien scientists
could find evidence of nuclear fallout
climate change or maybe a massive
asteroid that ended our existence or
maybe they'd even find us already living
on another
planet maybe 1 million years from now
you'd be an alien on board a Starship
that has just entered into orbit around
Earth I can't tell if you're joking or
not but despite your best efforts to
scan the planet below for intelligent
life you'd find nothing your trip down
to the surface would be slightly delayed
by an ongoing super volcanic eruption
the planet would be blanketed in the
darkness of Ash you might even have to
wait a few years for your alien crew to
clean it up before you could even
land finally you'd get approval to visit
Earth down there you'd find everything
to be Barren and
lifeless storms fires and earthquakes
would have erased nearly all signs of
immediately visible life but your team
of archaeologists and paleontologists
would know that if they wanted to find
evidence of past
civilizations they better start digging
you'd be investigating what are called
boundary layers these are geological
signatures that indicate a transition
from one period to the next so you'd be
looking for animal and plant fossils as
well as changes in rock layers you could
find a thin layer of clay that marks the
boundary to our anthropocenic era the
top layer would contain not much more
than small fossilized remains of a few
plant species the layer below would
contain older rock but not not only that
there would be an abundance of diverse
plant fossils this would be a
breakthrough for your team as they now
confirm there was some form of mass
extinction
period as you searched through this
layer the nature of what happened to
Earth over the past million years would
be revealed you'd discover an unnatural
amount of carbon deposits from fossil
fuel emissions evidence of global
temperature changes and widespread
chemical
pollutants but the effects of climate
change may have reversed themselves over
the 1 million years humans have been
absent if your team were to uncover the
regions where our Coastal populations
used to be you could excavate the
remains of cities relatively well
preserved in the sedimentary rock
imagine discovering the ancient subway
tunnels and sewers of New York but
nothing you would find would be in
pristine condition
bricks would have gone from their
characteristic red TO gray and steel
would have rusted and dissolve leaving
only imprints in the
soil finally you'd make the biggest
discovery of all fossilized human
bones just like the dinosaurs these too
would most likely only be found encased
in sedimentary rock almost all of the
fossils of dinosaurs that we discover
today are from species that would have
lived near lakes or rivers that flooded
floods covered their remains in mud and
silt very quickly and this prevented
their bones from rotting the same would
apply to Homo sapiens your alien team
would piece together the puzzle that
many of these human fossils were the
result of catastrophic floods or
tsunamis and based on how much these
bones have fused with the Rocks around
them your team could start to assemble a
Time timeline of our unfortunate
demise usually bones take decades to
decompose if buried in a dry environment
like a funeral casket they could last
for 100 years mummified bones can
survive thousands of years finding any
of these would tell your team that the
last humans to walk the earth weren't
all that far in the past but discovering
only fossilized remains would reveal our
Extinction point being further back than
you'd hoped there wouldn't be any
samples of soft tissues like muscles
just rocks that used to be bones oh but
you'd probably find fossilized plastic
in the layers of sedimentary rock 2 it's
not yet known how long plastic waste
needs to decompose into organic matter
it could take hundreds of years maybe
thousands or as as you and your crew
could discover
Millions what you'd keep your hopes up
for would be the real Holy Grail human
DNA the oldest DNA samples found in our
modern times date back
800,000 years and come from insects and
plants but studies conclude that DNA
could take about 7 million years to
disintegrate and Eureka you'd find human
DNA samples trapped in ice cores in what
was once Greenland now the big question
would be what do you do with them study
human genetics for scientific purposes
or have a little fun one idea would be
to clone these ancient humans you could
even create some kind of Jurassic Park
filled with people except it would be
called anthropos Park and based on all
that you'd put together about our tragic
history there would be so many
entertaining things to do in this
amusement park maybe you could clone
other animals and play a game of mass
extinction the winner would be the one
who could kill the most species in the
shortest amount of time you could dig
for hidden oil reserves increase carbon
emissions for fun to watch icebergs melt
or how about a game of nuclear
war sadly though you and the other
scientists probably wouldn't be able to
figure out what life was like for humans
at the end of our
civilization it's the oldest question on
Earth where did we come from some people
may think a Creator from above but what
if the hand that created Humanity wasn't
divine what if aliens brought life to
Earth how could a meteor carry life to
our
planet could microbes survive the cold
vacuum of
space and does alien life already exist
on
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens brought life to
earth when you think of aliens your
imagination might run wild with movie
scenes and xfiles reruns but technically
an alien includes anything not from
Earth and that broad definition opens up
some intriguing
possibilities in
2017 astronomers detected a mysterious
Chunk from an exoplanet that entered our
solar system called UA mua this
Interstellar object is made from
nitrogen ice the perfect radiation
shield for an organism that might be
hitching a ride after all if this
pancake shaped Rock can keep its ice
formation while flying through the
Galaxy then maybe life can not only
exist beyond the solar system but also
travel Frozen in space but if an object
like this slammed into Earth would the
organisms survive the
impact when our solar system was still
forming the chunk of rock that would
become Earth floated around completely
unprotected from meteors and asteroids
if an object like omua mua had landed on
Earth during that time it could have
brought microbes and other organisms
from deep
space this is called the panspermia
Theory which states that matter from
surrounding planets or objects from deep
space might have brought life to Earth
but how could we test this
Theory researchers aboard the
International Space Station found that
bacteria survived on the panels outside
the station even the extreme
temperatures of space didn't kill the
bacteria oh what does that prove well if
a spacecraft left from Mars with
microbial life attached those microbes
could survive the trip to
Earth but let's go back to the early
days of our planet almost 4 billion
years ago Earth went through a
bombardment period during this time
powerful meteor showers regularly rocked
the surface of our world and several
objects the size of omua mua about 800 M
long crack crashed into the Earth so if
there were microbes deep within those
meteors they might have been cushioned
from the impact and that's pretty
impressive considering meteors travel at
speeds of up to 100 km per second and
during that chaotic time life began
springing up all over Earth after all
bacteria can thrive in temperatures as
high as
113° or be preserved CED at -
196° so if those meteors had contained
microbial life it would have survived
the impact and possibly planted the
seeds of life but how could we know if
alien life is already
here well that evidence is harder to
find we still haven't found life
anywhere other than Earth so thinking
that life could have come from somewhere
else might be a bit of a
stretch but in a system 400 light years
away we have found the Elements of Life
using radio telescope technology Danish
researchers found glycol alide a simple
sugar needed to produce ribonucleic acid
or
RNA this is the macromolecule
responsible for making proteins and
coding genes glycol Al hide is floating
out there in space waiting for a carrier
to bring it to a world like
ours but maybe it's already here amino
acids and sugars the building blocks of
life come in two versions that mirror
each other we call this phenomenon
chirality and we refer to the versions
as left and right but on Earth all life
contains left-handed shaped amino acids
and right-handed shaped sugars and
that's unusual as scientists creating
amino acids in a lab would make half of
them left-handed and half right-handed
so single shapes in amino acids and
sugars could be an evolutionary function
or they could be an extraterrestrial
influence you know whether life came to
Earth from outside our solar system in a
rock or on the bottom of an alien's foot
it's hard to ignore this Theory when we
think about our place in the
universe but what if our planet has
spread life in the same
way what if ancient life escaped
Earth well that's a story for another
what
if
[Music]
researchers have detected strange radio
signals coming